I grew up on Batman and DC animated
series Justice League and uh X-Men and
all that stuff and then it when it
started getting bad I just went straight
to to manga stuff where the story lines
were still good Dragon Ball Z I grew up
with that as well and so then as I'm
getting older and look I'm a big fan of
static shock but it was it was preachy
it was okay I liked the show but it was
very preachy then I see Naruto and the
only preaching in it is
you know try and save your enemies like
the the character Arc for Naruto is that
you might I absolutely love this writing
some of the best writing I've ever done
have you ever read or watched
so I'll I'll give you the the the the
the the very quick breakdown the best of
my abilities for those that aren't
familiar Naruto is about a world where
there are ninjas and they can use inner
energy called chakra to do you know I
guess you'd call them spells anyway
Naruto is an orphan his dad died
sacrificing himself to save their
Village uh Naruto finds a teacher a guy
named Uriah who's this legendary Ninja
I would call them techniques instead of
spells but they like to throw fireballs
and stuff yeah and they can like walk on
water and so anyway Naruto gets a
teacher he's this old creepy guy he's a
pervert he wrote several books
uh
he he wrote these books because he was
you know inspired throughout his life
Naruto eventually encounters a villain
in the story arc who goes by the name of
Payne
and they fight and uh you find out that
this this guy Payne's real name is
nagato and he is a former uh pupil of
Jiraiya the same teacher Naruto now has
and then after this great battle
Naruto is like on the verge of defeating
this guy and then he says this famous
line of you know like I will save the
world or something like this you're like
I'm I'm gonna be the hero and and make
my enemies my friends and I'm gonna not
not allow the pain and it was a direct
quote
from Jiraiya's teacher who wrote this
book about a character and Jiraiya had
been quoting his pupil so basically what
happens is when dry is younger he trains
this kid whose idealistic wants to save
the world who says this inspiring line
as like a 13 year old jirai is so moved
by it he writes this book which is you
know he then teaches Naruto and so I
love this because the villain is now
facing down this younger you know ninja
who says his own quote back to him
realizing he's become the villain he
swore to fought and and Naruto now
embodies his past ideals and ideology
I'm like that was just brilliant wow it
was really really good that's Jerusalem
like I I can't do it justice you have to
read it but basically he's like he says
the line and then the villain's like
that's my quote you're saying it to me
like that's who I used to be that that's
what we're supposed to be doing and
we're supposed to be teaching lessons
like that in comics we're not supposed
to uh you know be trying to uh instill
politics or ideology in anyone we're
just supposed to be teaching kids like
basic morals like that how to be a hero
self-sacrifice put others before you yet
save the villain of course there's very
little of that like you mentioned
earlier with Captain Marvel that's the
funniest part about that is it's so
simple
but it's so simple to understand that uh
Captain America telling a story of cell
sacrifice and wanting to help his fellow
man and even the idea that you could
even tell a story now about an
idealistic person wanting to protect or
wanting to serve his country they
probably wouldn't even do that story
let's let's talk about the first big
three of Marvel Iron Man a military
industrialist who's selling weapons for
profit has a profound experience and
realizes his weapons are being sold to
both sides causing this conflict and
then says I'm not doing this anymore and
it destroys his company so he builds
himself a suit of armor taken to his own
hands and then he fights the
military-industrial complex warmonger
Iron Monger to stop it from happening
and then the company does better than
ever they do renewable energy pop like
that is an amazing Arc of a guy who had
everything thing and was this cocky
a-hole who still is for but he then
decides it's not worth it to be a part
of this problem Captain America scrawny
young guy wants to Surf his country we
should talk about the cultural victories
of the first Marvel movies are then Thor
an arrogant prince who has everything
gets his powers taken from him and comes
to realize humility I'm like these are
Great Character artists that's Stan Lee
but yeah I think I mean you know Stan
Lee I mean those are his stories you
understand like uh we don't have guys
like that anymore you want to know why
Marvel is in the Rut that it is it's
because Stan Lee's gone why is Disney
the way it is Walt Disney's gone why is
Star Wars the way it is George Lucas
sold it I mean you know there are rare
creative Geniuses that come along and
they have the heart uh and the the
empathy to be able to write stories that
touch people in a in a in a unique way
uh and and and build their childhoods
and then when they leave or they die
Gerard Tolkien gone than other people
paralytically inherit it and destroy it
these are people who are forged in the
world surrounded by War that's
absolutely the lessons being told now
what we have are people who are forged
by gluttony oh yeah we were talking
about writing stories when we were what
they're owed when we were when we were
reviewing prey we were talking about how
nobody in this movie looks like they've
lived through anything actually
difficult in their entire life nobody
looks like they've lived in the
wilderness nobody looks like they've
ever had to hunt for any type of food in
their life right so people are trying to
write stories now from a world that they
just can't understand but Stan Lee was
he silverage did was he around in the
early days yeah yeah Stan Lee was
interesting because uh World War II
veteran sorry World War II veteran uh
yeah he was around in the Golden Age too
but uh the Silver age he launched it he
really did launch the Silver age uh even
though before there was Flash and Green
Lantern Hal Jordan in this that really
launched the Silver age but Stanley was
so disgusted by the politics of comics
in 1950s with the comics code and the
way things had become so silly that he
just wanted to quit and he told his wife
I am so inspired by this he told his
wife he wanted to quit and his wife said
just do one your way before you quit
1961's Fantastic Four number one that's
that was him doing it his way launched
the Marvel Revolution that's when the
Silver age Stan Lee enlisted in 1942
after the attack on Pearl Harbor what a
guy what a guy it's one of the things
gone are the days there there used to be
dozens and dozens of actors all who had
served in the military who had extensive
military whether through draft or
because they enlisted because they
believed in that country and as that
generation of people has died off you
start seeing that less and less of the
stories less and less of our country of
our culture's empathy towards its own
country is gone we talk about this every
time an actor passes away that was older
right it's like they were born at a time
when there was a relative amount of
support for America and they believed in
their country and they believed in in
what it stood for now I believe a lot of
that has kind of been manufactured in a
lot of ways by the media and that
there's a lot of problems there but you
don't see that anymore I think like Adam
drivers like the only one I can think of
off the top of my head that's a newer
age actor that served in the military
and you just don't see that and it's
going to be it's going to lead to even
more anti-American storytelling whether
it's in comics or in film and television
you know you know what's interesting
about manga is that there is a common
trope
um Black Clover have you ever heard of
it no another really great show really
great manga um I've not uh I stopped
after a while but in this world
everybody not everybody but many people
will get a magic grimoire and magic
abilities so one day a grimoire comes to
you and then you have your book of
spells and you can cast certain spells
and certain elements there's one kid who
really wants to be a a magic Knight and
work for the you know he wants to join
the service basically but he has no
magic powers so Unity does he works out
until he's so incredibly powerful that
when he's in these like when he's in the
trials to become you know a knight or
whatever he has no spells but he just
like they he's extremely powerful like
he jumps and the ground cracks and he
shoots in the air super fast and they're
like what when when they first see him
with no magic they're like what a
pathetic loser how could he even try and
bother but then he's so physically
powerful that he actually ends up
winning and then there's like an arc
where he a book does appear to him it's
an anti-magic book he does a sword and
all of his capabilities are basically
his physical ability to wield it there's
other arcs too like anti-magic and stuff
but the general idea was you can work
hard and if you do you can be a magic
Knight it's a rocky Story I mean it
works every single time it's tried just
a normal guy who's determined you know
he's an underdog the Underdog Story he
works his way up and through hard work
uh through diligence uh and through
faith all of these things he becomes a
hero and self-sacrifice you can tell
that story over and over and over again
he beats unbeatable odds uh you know
just out of sheer will and determination
nobody's ever going to get tired of that
you could tell that story with a million
different characters they're doing it in
Japan right now that's why they're
kicking our ass they're raising our kids
right I mean look I'm uh
I like it I think I think a lot of it is
really great not all of it some of it's
stupid you know nobody not everything is
perfect uh bleach for instance also very
very very good more of a uh reluctant
thrust into Adventure hero's journey uh
still great story great ideas you're not
getting beaten over the head with the
with the preaching yeah you know it
seems like I'm thinking about the age of
comics we have the Golden Age we have
the Silver age which ended like the 70s
is that about right yeah then the Bronze
Age was like you know the 70s through
the the 1980s people are saying what
this is today is called the Iron Age
that's funny a term it's getting worse
no no the Iron Age the Iron Age is is
really uh you know independent creators
rising up and taking over the culture
because we have no choice thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members on only shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next time